[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
i'm fraser nelson editor of the
spectator and your host for this week
inflation has hit britain hard but if
we're in recession then why are there so
many jobs kate andrews joins me to try
to get to the bottom of this mystery liz
trusts will probably be solving that
mystery when she's elected prime
minister but who's she going to have in
her cabinet katie bowles and isabel
hardman join me to discuss
and britain isn't the only country
heading for a new female prime minister
georgia maloney is set to take reigns in
italy after the election there next
month but is she going to really be the
most right-wing leader italy's hudson's
mussolini and if so how worried do we
need to be
and this big brother going to be
regulating the internet and indeed
internet shows like this jonathan
sumption joins me to discuss the online
safety bill and whether it will as he
fears cast a censor's chill done
everything broadcast on youtube or said
online
salman rushdie is still recovering in
new york hospital after being attacked
last weekend what does that attack say
about freedom of speech and how strongly
is it being defended
i talked to our columnist lionel shriver
about who thinks that terrorism is
winning
and finally is it too early to proclaim
the death of cryptocurrencies they've
staged quite a rally in the last few
days matthew lin joins me to discuss
whether this is for real or just another
crypto mirage
if you haven't tried the spectator
magazine before then do give us a try
we've got
a rather unusually generous introductory
offer right now one pound a week for the
first year you can avail yourself of
this rather uneconomic for us anyway
offer on spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash tv offer also you can subscribe to
this show for free the week in 60
minutes by clicking on the red subscribe
button then if you click on the bell
button you'll be told every time there's
a new episode
so first has britain entered a strange
kind of recession technically the
economy is shrinking right now and
probably we're going to be told we're in
a technical recession in a few weeks
time but if you go outside you'll see
that companies still can't find enough
workers and the job figures this week
showed vacancies almost twice the level
they were over the last 10 years so is
this a bust or a boom i'm joined by kate
andrews our economics editor to try to
get to the bottom of this mystery kate
what's going on
really difficult to say but you raise an
interesting point fraser because
historically we would associate a
recession with linking
negative economic growth and rising
unemployment and at the moment as you
point out in the states we're not seeing
that america is in recession and yet its
latest uh jobs update was rather
spectacular over 500 000 jobs were added
to the u.s economy last month
unemployment in the u.s is well below
four percent as it is in the uk i think
in the us it's at a 50-year low
so we're not seeing the normal coupling
that we would get between negative
economic growth and rising unemployment
i think there are a few theories and i'm
not 100 behind any of them but if we're
brainstorming why this could be
less so in the us but certainly in the
uk the main economic policy of the past
two years has been to protect jobs if we
think about one of the most expensive
schemes throughout the covent emergency
the furlough scheme when we were taking
major hits to the economy all of the
effort and resources was put behind
keeping people in their jobs so when the
economy reopened people could go
straight back to work i think the
furlough scheme turned out to be a big
success i was skeptical at first i i
think it is
well justified when you look at the data
so we're starting from a very low
unemployment rate
also recession is defined by two
consecutive quarters of negative growth
but that can mean wildly different
things depending on how negative that
growth is and at the moment in the u.s
and in the uk i would say that we're
looking at really stagnant growth and
that stagnant growth can be on the
slightly positive side or the slightly
negative side in the u.s i think in q1
you saw growth fall by 1.6
in q2 it was 0.9 percent here in the uk
we're not officially in recession yet
people think in q3 it'll technically be
defined as that but in q2 we had
0.1
fall in growth i don't want to
underestimate how serious that is
because if we look at the forecast for
the next few years uh possibly even
after that completely stagnant growth
not seeing that uptick in gdp is going
to mean countless opportunities lost a
lack of prosperity people feeling worse
off so it's not to say it's not serious
um but we're not seeing that usual
recession where there's a major dip like
for example we had during kovid we're
seeing something that's more
stagnant and i i think the last thing i
would say is
we should be prepared for unemployment
figures to go up so usually businesses
when we go into recession they lose
customers they lose profit they find
that they can't pay their bills and they
have to lay off staff
at the moment job vacancies in the u.s
and the uk are at record highs here in
the uk it looks like it's peaked but
it's only fallen to 1.2 million so if
you want a job out there they're plenty
to go get
but as inflation continues to ramp up
and as consumer behavior changes
especially with more rising energy bills
in the future we could see that
businesses decide actually i can't
afford all the staff that i'm
advertising for right now so we
shouldn't get too comfortable in these
very high job vacancy rates it's
positive news right now if you want to
go out and get a new job or you're
looking you're seeking a job but i i
wouldn't get too comfortable in the
notion that it'll be there forever one
of the things i'd like to explore about
the british situation case is that when
you go you know when you go out to a
restaurant and stay in a hotel you it's
rare that you don't see adverts for help
wanted everybody seems to to you know
you get someone sells even now are only
open four or five days a week not seven
because they simply can't get the staff
um
and yet we've got you know we're
technically in a recession so those two
things are strange to put together but
when you look at the number of
immigrants quite often brexit is blamed
for this well the uk left the eu and
therefore we can't get the polish
waiters or the czechoslovakian child
carers but when you look at the
immigration figures out this week there
is a record number something like 6.6
million and
foreign nationals in the uk workforce
that's almost one in five workers in
britain is an immigrant that is a
greater proportion than even the united
states but when you look at the uk
figures and it seems to me anyway as if
people who haven't that furlough scheme
that you were saying was a great success
seems to have not been particularly good
at unwinding we still seem to be having
a furlough hangover where a lot of
people weren't working during the
pandemic and didn't return to work
thereafter and that not immigration is
what's blowing the hole in the jobs
market so there are a few things to
break down there fraser and i you're
completely right if we actually look at
the data for migration to the uk and the
number of migrant workers we have here
it does not look like there's been a
brexit fall off now it's important to
remember that during brexit they
estimate that up to a million people did
go home so that was an issue for a time
but now it does seem as if the numbers
are balancing out so this idea that
brexit inevitably and automatically
means that we're going to have a labor
shortage simply isn't the case labor
shortages are being experienced
throughout europe in the united states
as well in the u.s the labor market is
very tight in the uk it is we resemble
the us a bit more in that sense and we
resemble europe a bit more in this
energy crisis so in many ways we're
getting the worst of both worlds but
migration doesn't seem to be the
immediate problem as you've pointed out
i think fraser you actually dug up the
data we do have about five million
people of working age missing from the
workforce right now um
no doubt furlough has played a role in
that and when i say it was a success i
mean it was a success in what it sought
to do which was make sure those jobs
were available for people to return
immediately but there have been so many
unforeseen consequences to the decisions
made to lock down in the first place and
all the policies that followed from that
and i think a bigger criticism isn't the
furlough scheme or the design but just
how long it went on for i think you can
make the case that it went on certainly
six months too long perhaps even longer
that once we had the most vulnerable
vaccinated you know once we were in a
position to meaningfully open up society
which we were originally told by
politicians was going to be in the early
part of 2021 and that didn't happen
perhaps that's when furlough should have
started to wind down that's when we
should have gotten people back to work
so i think the extent and that the
timeline for which furlough went on
probably has led to some of these more
negative repercussions for people not
wanting to come back to the workforce
right away
but if you look at the unemployment
headline rate i think it's very hard to
criticize it that unemployment barely
peaked over five percent
during this
insane economic crisis during this last
categorization error i mean sure
unemployment might not be five percent
but when you look at all of those on out
of work benefits as we say in the
leading article of the magazine this
week it is 13 of the workforce or on out
of work benefits of some kind now just
because fewer than half of those are
categorized as unemployed
doesn't necessarily make a mistake it
seems to me as if furlough the
furlough's scheme has created a lot more
damage to the jobs market than the
supporters admit
i think it's really difficult to go back
and say gosh if there hadn't been a
furlough scheme what would have happened
maybe you would have seen the uk push
harder to open up faster as happened in
the us the us started opening up in
summer 2020 and never really went back
into proper lockdown but it's very
difficult to argue given the fact that
the government was regulating who could
sit on a park bench let alone who could
go to work when you were supposed to go
outside and all the rest of it that you
could have really at the same time also
said to people there's going to be no
support for you when you can't go do
this job that we're mandating right now
you don't do as we say in the leader
this week fraser i think we should be
looking at welfare reform a lot of
people are worried about talking about
reform right now because they have the
fear of recession leaving over them
and often times you don't want to talk
about these kinds of reforms when you
think there's going to be a serious
economic downturn but given how many job
vacancies we have i think there are
reforms that have been made be made as
the leader points out at the moment if
you're on universal credit you can get
out of a meeting with a jobs advisor by
working nine hours a week with so many
jobs being offered in this economy right
now that could be up to 15 or 20. so i
think there are changes that could be
made even with the prospect of recession
looming but i think that is the key to
focus on not necessarily furlough
because of course the us didn't do
furlough and yet we're talking about two
countries that are suffering from
similar labor market issues despite one
doing furlough and one doing something
very different kate andrews thanks very
much indeed
so the prequel to game of thrones is
released next week about the house of
tragerian which was eventually captured
by an underestimated woman who went on
to slay all of her opponents and take
the throne in related news liz tross is
now very close to being made leader of
the conservative party with a few more
weeks to go left of the tory leadership
campaign the she has got more mp and
support now than russia smack and the
polls still suggest she's ahead amongst
the general members by a ratio of three
to one but the race still continues in
this week's magazine katie balls looks
at what sort of government liz trois
mind up might end up running and she
joins me now as does isabel hardman um
so katie list trust has got the
reputation of being quite a you know
amiable she likes to laugh she's good
fun but not always the most forgiving of
person you wouldn't want to be one of
her enemies yet she will leave this
leadership campaign with quite a few
enemies what's going to happen to them
when their cabinet is announced
well i think some of these and perhaps
uh more than not will be heading to
political siberia
you have a situation where i think in
some cases such as for example in the
case of dominic rob who is a rishi sunak
backer who i think is seen to have been
particularly problematic by the trust
camp because he wrote an op-ed in which
he likened liz truss's economic plans to
an electoral suicide note i don't
there's any chance really of dominic
robb having a role in liz truss's
government or being offered one now
given what he said he would probably say
no you would imagine at the offer but
the offer won't be coming i think also
figures such as michael gove who has not
endorsed rishi sunak but who i think has
long been a foe of liz trusses when it
comes to the cabinet some say they have
a very jovial relationship but i think
jokes aside they disagree on lots of big
issues particularly trade
and uh there is a sense in the trust
camp that when gov is given a position
partly because he's a very skilled
minister he tends to extend his brief i
mean you know dip into other people's
departments what they're doing and
therefore it's probably safer to have
them on the back benches
and there's lots of questions such as if
she actually has to lead a government
will she be doing some big unifying
measures
i think part of the issue is so many
jobs have been promised or at least
supporters of liz trust believe they
have been promised jobs that there's not
actually that much space um to offer too
many uh across to the other camp i think
rishi scenic will be offered a job but
um few would expect him to take that and
it's unlikely to be a particularly
senior role and the let's of course see
what the voting margin is if liz trust
wins so that's michael gove out that's
rishi sunak out that's dominic grab out
all pretty big beasts and by the way
michael gove hasn't said a word against
liz trust during this campaign but but
you're saying it's because interestingly
an ideological split that she's more of
a free trader where michael gove has
been more protectionist over the years
and she you i mean during government
list trust ended up in the wrong
on the losing side of that argument and
i remember one um i heard anyway of one
meeting in cabinet where she was
basically saying look boris um we're
never going to get a deal with america
if agriculture is not on the table and
michael gove was chief amongst his
voices saying we are not going to let
our agricultural sector be as he put it
put it on the altar of
a sacrificial gift to america so fair
enough they but and they disagree but
when this trust becomes prime minister
do you think we're going to get
more of a free trading because she lost
out to gov in that trade argument
there's nobody to lose to lose to her
now so do you think she's going to have
a change of policy and be more free
trading and actually put for example
agriculture on the table in a free trade
deal with america
so so i think
her government will be very pro free
trade and also i mean you mentioned
michael gove i remember at the time of
that dispute um writing a column where a
trust supporter and branded them the
waitrose protectionists and this
included uh michael gove i think george
eustis too they they were regarded by uh
trusted supporters as the access of evil
accidents
and so i think there is a question as to
of course how far does her rhetoric go
when she has to get mps to support
measures um but i do think if you look
at the people who will probably be in
the prime positions so quasi-cuatang is
likely to be the chancellor
um you know liz trust as prime minister
is very pro free market um there will i
think be a switch in the balance of
power and actually moving towards more
ambitious deals because i think that uh
liz trust would probably like to go
further for example in that australia
free trade deal and she then she was
able to do partly because of the what
she was coming against in whitehall and
also from various forces within the
cabinet might she revisit the australia
trade deal in katy
well i think there's there's a chance to
try and revisit some of these things of
course she's gonna have a pretty full
entry when she first gets in so i think
they want to be more ambitious with the
free trade deals and i think australia
is seen as a key ally but of course the
government has now changed in australia
and i think when she first comes in of
course that the biggest issue on her
table will be cost of living and i
imagine that will occupy quite a lot of
time within the first few weeks
so free trade reforms isabel perhaps
more trade deals what would this trust
do domestically well in lots of ways we
haven't had a great deal of detail about
what she plans to do domestically um but
i think there are some interesting hints
one of them is um on the nhs which is
obviously gonna be a huge issue
electorally uh over the next couple of
years in the run-up to the election and
we've seen increasingly distressing
stories about people being uh you know
stuck under makeshift shelters whilst
waiting uh for 14 hours for an ambulance
and so on and we're only going to hear
more and more of these um
stories so that the pressure to do
something on the nhs is going to grow
and the hint that liz trust has dropped
there is um
slightly concerning for those of us who
follow
nhs reform which is that she seems to
want to do more of it even though the
current um changes that have only just
been enacted in the health and social
care act 2022
are only just bedding in she seems to
want to flatten the layers of management
within the health service which would
require um a huge amount of upheaval at
a time that i'm not sure the health
service has any elastic left and
certainly not for the sort of things
like moving managers around and and
changing structures that take up a huge
amount of time and don't necessarily
impact on you know clinical outcomes
waiting times and she's only got
something like 18 months realistically
before the next election so if you're
looking at an incredibly condensed
period of time
nhs reform typically takes a year to
think of the reform and four years to
carry it out so what she might try to
crunch something like this in a because
let's face it the nhs is already looking
like it's in crisis let alone a winter
crisis we're looking at 10 flu levels in
australia which are quite high we're
also looking at the potential of
pensioners dying of the cold i mean we
all know the link between house
temperatures and the over 80s ending up
in hospital so nhs is looking for an
incredibly difficult period of time but
you think liz trusts would still do nhs
reform in the middle of what it's
looking like in an interest crisis well
look she said that repeatedly throughout
this leadership contest that she thinks
that the nhs should have fewer middle
managers that there should be a collapse
in the layers of management within the
health service i suspect that that may
not end up being a massive reform agenda
once she comes into
office for all the reasons that you just
listed and i suspect there are two
reasons for her saying it one is
probably that you know she is
essentially a she's a think tanker
politician isn't she she's someone who
likes coming up with ideas likes
challenging the consensus
finds the way in which
policies and structures operate
interesting but doesn't necessarily sit
back and think well is now the time to
be doing this is this the right thing to
do or even um i think some of her
critics who i've been talking to over
the past few days and would say thinking
about what's happening at the moment and
the second thing is
people just love bashing nhs management
and which is kind of ironic because it
was introduced by margaret thatcher um
which who is you know obviously the
person who we must all sort of say peace
be upon her during this contest as much
as often as possible um but uh she was
the one who who recognized that the
health service was in complete chaos
without any managers with these sort of
bizarre committees of doctors that were
sort of run along post-war military
lines um so again i think that's
probably a sign that trust hasn't looked
into this too much
then we've got um just moving on from
from the nhs which i always find hard to
do and we do have the we've got the
debate over handouts um in relation to
the cost of living crisis but what might
she do about welfare what might she do
about um economically inactive people
and the people who rishi sunak talks
about quite a lot who
are on unemployment benefit at a time of
a tight labor market that's uh five
million of them yeah there's rather a
lot
to approach anything like this she will
need a crack team of commandos around
her do you know anything about for
example who are chief of staff's going
to be who she's going in for delivery
so there's been lots of rumors and i
think
team trusts are very keen to not look
too much as though they are planning for
government so as to look as you know uh
they've decided the the the result of
the leadership contest was already a
done deal
um but we know that liz trusted now
spending about half her time planning
for government the polls put her very
far ahead and some of the rumors for
example you've had people say oh david
frost the former uh brexit negotiator he
should be her chief of staff and he has
been backing liz trust you also people
pointing to david canzini uh who has
been a number 10 under boris johnson um
saying that actually david canzini could
have that type of role i think one of
the issues of david kanzini is actually
some of the boris johnson loyalists many
of them are backing this trust are
actually a bit skeptical about david
kenzie when you break it down into the
number 10 factions and i think the name
which i think uh
you haven't heard so much about i think
is a probable pick is actually ruth
porter and now ruth porter is a former
advisor to liz trust
liz trust i think foreign career has
always made sure to keep in close
contact with those who have worked for
her who she has worked well with and
trust even if they are no longer on the
payroll so to speak
and uh reports have been playing a very
key role in terms of the campaign and i
think the reason that it seems quite
likely she'll get such a senior role is
there a sense that a i think liz trust
wants to surround herself with people
she trusts we know it's going to be a
very tough um you know first 100 days
but also people who understand her and
i've worked her previously i think um as
opposed to perhaps you know the bigger
names amongst the mps
isabelle and katie thanks very much
indeed
now to italy where there's going to be a
general election next month and it looks
set to be won by georgia maloney the
brothers of italy party she set up only
10 years ago is coming first in the
opinion polls and it looks set to put
her in power in coalition with matteo
salvini whose fortunes have waned as
hers have waxed and with her former boss
and silvio berlusconi who is yes still
going
so what kind of leader will she be
if you read around you'll find some
words associated with her pretty
regularly far right
and post fascist so has italy taken a
pretty dramatic right words turn or are
the descriptions of her simply unfair
i'm delighted to be joined by francesco
jubilai who's written a biography of
miss maloney out now in italian and
spanish not yet in english but francesco
tell us where would you place her on the
political spectrum she said she sent her
right is she or is she a bit further to
the right than that
georgia maloney she is both a center
right and a conservative she is not a
far-right politician as some a liberal
media and has some
liberal politics tried to describe her
her in the last two or three years
george maloney did a lot of
job about her political position and she
became a totally conservative leader of
course she's an italian leader and when
we talk about italian conservatism we
have to say that there are some point in
common with for example the american or
the english conservative landscape but
in the same times
an italian political leader is a leader
of a latin conservatism and when we talk
about latin conservatism we talk about a
conservative thought with some
difference for example in the economic
issues our conservatism is a
conservative that is more focused on the
welfare state but in the same times
she is also hoping to some classical
liberal view of the economy but when
someone tried to describe george malone
as fascist when someone tried to
describe a brother of italy as a
neo-fascist or as a post-fascist party
that's a way to not understand what is
happening in italy because we can't say
that 25
of the italian are fascist of course it
means that brother of italy is the party
that is voted by some people that are
linked to the middle class but in the
same times in the political party that
is voted by the people come from the
working class that in the past election
voted for the left so she is a totally
conservative politician
so can you tell us a bit about her
policies then i mean and where is she on
on the family where is she on the
economy i mean saying marine le pen uh
in france so she is quite um
quite socialist almost in her policies
she's a believer in state intervention
whereas where is ms maloney on that or
also let's take russia we knew that
matteo salvini had been leaning towards
some vladimir putin's sympathies as is
quite common in the um some of the more
right-wing movements in europe
where is miss maloney in the great
ukraine versus russia divide
i think there are many differences
between georgia maloney and
marine le pen
especially from a political history
for example in marine le pen and
resemble national i i can define this
political party more a post-ideological
party and brother of italy is a more a
conservative party and is the party that
came from the center right and the
italian right uh tradition so this is a
quite big difference and another
different of course is the foreign
politics the foreign politics of the
front national and the foreign politics
of other a national populist party all
over europe is a more
linked sometime in the position of a
europe that is between the russian world
and the american and english word
brother of italy is in the foreign
politics is the total atlantic political
party so when the war started in ukraine
the position of george maloney was very
clear and her position is quite similar
to for example the position of the torus
or is quite similar to the position of
the republican party in the united
states so what georgia maloney say is
that
italy
must stay with europe and italy must
stay with the or the western countries
so she condemned immediately the attack
made by russia in
ukraine so this is quite a big
difference when we talked about a
brother of italy we have also to
underline that is a political party that
want to underline the importance of the
the family and the
the vision of the brother of italy
concerning the family is more or less
similar to the vision of the catholic
church so is for example in favor of
helping
the the nativity of people in italy we
have a really strong problem uh with the
birth rate we have a really low birth
rate and brother of italy underline how
is important to do some politics in
favor of the birth rate but in the same
times what is really interesting in the
economic polity of brother of italy is
that in one way is the political party
in favor for example of the law taxation
is the political party in favor of a low
bureaucracy you know that we have a high
bureaucracy and high taxation
unfortunately in our country so is a
politic in favor of the entrepreneurial
world but in the same time she is also a
political party in favor of the lower
class for example if we look
in the election in roma or in milano in
the last years we can say that in this
in the richest neighbor of the city in
the city center of the city the people
voted for the left but in the mo in the
poorest a neighbor of the city where
there are some also social problems some
problem with immigration the people
voted for brother of italian for the
central right because is a political
party that also try to help the people
that are in a difficult social situation
right and but of course i mean sweden
for example there's a country which
wants to do everything it can to
increase the birth rate so you can say
there's nothing necessarily the right
wing about that but it is the case isn't
it that miss maloney is against for
example the adoption of children by gay
couples so there she is more socially
conservative perhaps aligned with the
church
but there are another couple of things
when you try to read people you try to
understand it from a distance you see
look she's got as her party logo the the
flame symbol which is controversial some
of her opponents have asked her to drop
it because of the way it can be confused
with with fascism she doesn't condemn
fascism she said she's not a fascist but
she doesn't as opposed to other members
of the right really go out of her way to
say that fascism was a terrible evil and
isn't it also the case that mussolini's
niece is one of her candidates and that
some of her party members were in
trouble when they were caught on video
doing the roman salute
i i think that when we talk about
fascism first of all we have to say that
fascism ended with the death of
mussolini i don't say that but the renzo
de felicia that is the most important
historian of fascism and the rent of the
felicia was a link with the communist
party so it was a left historian it
wasn't a conservative or a right
historian but rental reflection explains
that fascism ended with the death of
mussolini so georgia maloney born in the
seventies and brother of italy born 10
years ago so it's quite some way funny
to to say that she's a fascist or that
her party is the fascist party when
they are not linked at all with the
history of fascism also because in 1995
in italy there was an important a period
where the so-called movement social
italiano that was
in some way in a post fascist party
decided to change and became alliance
nationale and when the political party
landed nationally born in 1995
they say explicitly that they are not
linked with fascism and brother of italy
arrived after aleanta nationale and
georgia melania explained in many
situations that of course she is not
fascist also some days ago but
when someone define himself as a
conservative is of course not a fascist
because a conservative is not a fascist
but what we have to say that sometimes
the the left and sometimes also some
liberal media try to attack not
to the the program of the maloney or the
program of brother fetal but they try to
attack her only to say that she's linked
with fascism and this is a totally big
mistake and also the people that are the
most influential people inside the
brother of italy are some young people
that are 30 40 or maybe 50 but they they
have a totally different history from
some neo-fascist group that of course
exists in italy there are some small
political parties that are new fashion
there are some a small group that are
linked to fascism but they are not
linked with brother of italy that is a
total institutional political party that
governs some important region all over
the country that is in the parliament
from many years so i think that is a
narrative that don't help to understand
why george maloney became so powerful in
our country
francesca jubilante thanks for joining
us on spectator tv
now the online safety bill is still
making its way through the house of
commons kemi baidnick in her leadership
campaign said she would scrap it because
it was a censors charter she thought now
and that's disputed by nadine doris for
secretary of state for culture who says
that kemi baden has got it all wrong but
this bill is one that protects free
speech damian collins who's taking the
bill through the house of commons now
and technology minister he says that
those who think it imperils or endangers
free speech in any way are simply
confused they've got the wrong end of
the stake and they've misunderstood what
the bill is really about
now this is all pretty important if this
bill goes through and it does what its
critics fear
then what you're watching right now
might suddenly disappear from cyberspace
if one of the censorship bots decides
that we've transgressed a rule or is
that a dystopian piece of hysterical
nonsense
it's difficult because it's pretty big
bill but we have sought in this week's
magazine a legal opinion from jordan
consumption lord sumption a former
supreme court justice who joins me now
and jonathan first of all
is there a threat to free speech in this
bill how do you see it
there's a threat to free speech in part
of it
what narrative doris has been saying is
there's nothing actually in the bill
which requires censorship
and that is strictly speaking true
but it's misleading because the whole
scheme of the bill is designed to create
a a culture of sin self-censorship
self-censorship is much more difficult
to control and that is what the real
object not of the whole of this bill but
of the most objectionable parts of it
so
so how would the government encourage
self-censorship how would that work who
who would be doing the censoring
well the
parts of the bill which i think are
relatively inoffensive
uh are
the bits about um
pornographic images and the bits about
material that's actually illegal
and whenever nadine doris goes on about
this bill those are the bits that she is
really talking about but the problem
about the bill is that it also
sets up a system for controlling what is
called legal uh but harmful material
so
material that you can communicate
perfectly freely by any other means
is going to be to some extent controlled
uh by um
by this bill
now the real advice about this is that
it is actually impossible
to define
in any very precise way what is harmful
the bill attempts to define it as
meaning any
uh how any psychological or physical
harm which is extraordinarily broad
and it goes on to say that if anybody
does anything harmful to themselves or
to other people as a result of something
that's appeared on the internet either
because they saw it themselves or
because somebody told them about it
then that too is within the definition
so this is a wholly subjective
definition
that's that's the topic i mean say
somebody's listening to our conversation
now and finds what you're saying
distressing i mean
obviously that can't come in with the
scope of this bill you can't be held
responsible for how our hundred thousand
subscribers to this channel how any one
of them might react to to what they see
or hear
well the definition is so wide
that the only way that it can be given
any real precision at all
is for the government to say what they
mean
by harm
and
that is what the bill authorizes them to
do
it provides that ofcom the regulator
is going to issue guidance
and recommendations
under the guise of rules of practice
but these rules of practice are
ultimately under the control of the
government
because the rules of practice have to be
submitted in draft to the government
they can be changed by the government
the government can say what they regard
as harmful and indeed they have already
said that they would include among
harmful things what they call
misinformation and disinformation which
means things that other people think may
not be true
now here we are arguing about what this
bill actually does
does that mean
that the government is entitled to say
that you and i fraser are engaging in
misinformation and disinformation
because we happen to disagree with the
way that nadine doris chooses to define
these these the concept of harm
all government policies believe are
based on the idea
that they are in the public interest
so if you challenge government policies
is it going to be said against you that
you are harming people because you are
seeking to undermine something that the
government thinks is good
this is again the very fact that one's
asking these questions indicates how
very vague
the concepts
involved in legal but harmful material
are
so if it's so vague then this would give
any secretary of state whether nadine
doris or a corbynite successor the power
to say there's a knockdown for example
that people like you from memory serves
you were a troublemaker during the
lockdown you challenged quite a lot of
what the government says now say i was a
secretary of state i could say look i
think this assumption chap is um
undermining public health and he's
making the government contradicting the
government message i therefore i'm going
so would i the power then the secretary
of state to decide that what jonathan's
assumption says is harmful and youtube
or facebook or google or whoever but
they can they can all be punished if
they
go on to broadcast
what you say on
on social media or an interview like
this
they couldn't be as crude as that
they couldn't have guidance saying that
you can't publicize sumption's views
what they would do is they would
encapsulate assumptions views in a
statement of things that were to be
treated as harmful
now this isn't a fantasy because you may
remember that during the lockdown
the uh
social media were quite keen uh to carry
favor with the government i think they
were mainly concerned to avoid a system
of statutory regulation which they've
now got or may get
um
and
they therefore voluntarily uh instituted
a system of monitoring
and as a result
i wasn't taken down but david davies was
taken down when he was making perfectly
rational points
against the lockdown
talk radio was taken down
when
but they have a persistent record of
challenging government policy on kovid
and this is a mentality that is actually
very widespread i think that one of the
most sinister things is that the royal
society which is society
dedicated for the last three centuries
uh to scientific truth
should have put out a document urging
that we should have
legislation to stop people
um
challenging vaccines now i am in all in
favor of vaccines i think that the
people who object to vaccines are just
silly
but if people want to say that the earth
is flat
then i do not think that there's any
right to stop them but doing it but the
problem is this is happening now the
online safety bill hasn't been passed
and yet we're already seeing david davis
when he did a speech attacking lockdown
regulations that was removed from
youtube we saw the um i think we had the
um the morning star kind of a far-left
newspaper its um facebook page
disappeared this censorship is happening
all of the time so what i don't
understand is why you think this bill
would change anything surely if this is
happening is bad but are you saying the
bill would make it worse
yes because
the bill requires
steps to be taken
in relation to the so-called legal but
harmful material which you first of all
got to find in the vastness of the
internet
and
when you've got a category of material
which is completely undefined except by
reference to a completely undefined
command of harm that it may cause to a
completely undefined group of people
how are you going to cater for this well
either
you do what the government says
or else
you simply take no risk at all
and take it down anyway
remember that this is a scheme which is
enforced
by enormous fines 10 of global turnover
many billions of pounds
and by personal criminal liability
internet companies are required to
nominate somebody
who can be
prosecuted if they get this wrong
now that person is not going to take on
that responsibility without having some
control over what appears on the
platform that he's working for
and what that means is that he's going
to exclude everything that he thinks has
the slightest prospect of causing harm
in the view of the regulator
right so say i am uk chief executive of
youtube the channel we're watching this
on under the bill and currently if i'm
wrong here i could be on the hook for
ten percent of global turnover we're
talking billions of pounds here if i
transgress was a lot so if you get it
wrong the potential fine it is runs into
the millions
now of course i'm not going to have
humans um
you know when we recorded this show we
upload it it will be scanned by a bot i
think there are hundreds of hours of
youtube content gets uploaded every
minute and there are thousands of
sentences so it's going to be robots who
are already programmed to scan what
we're saying to find out if we're i
don't know promoting drug selling or
terrorism or something that there will
be key words if we were to say them now
they'll be flagging up to the bot so are
you saying that this bot apparatus as it
were will simply be increased to catch
politically sensitive words and be wrong
and will be told if in doubt cut it out
what they will do
is they will take
not single words but blocks of text
which they will take from a sample
of
things that they think shouldn't appear
and the algorithm will then link that
with other
um
with other
material that it regards as relevant and
it'll do the same about images but but
but text is is actually much more
serious because that's actually where
serious debate happens
as well as
mischief making
so
the problem here is
that the absence of definition is bad
enough
but since it can only actually be done
through algorithms these are pretty
indiscriminate algorithms do not
they're very insensitive to context they
don't distinguish between irony
and straight statements
they
they invariably catch too much and they
will be programmed on the safe side to
protect the internet company
which will increase the tendency for
them to catch too much
i don't think that it is ever legitimate
to seek to establish a regime of control
over material that you cannot define
except by reference
to guidance which is essentially
produced under the supervision of the
government
all right so we tried to get nadine
doris and damian collins on to join us
here that neither were able to but they
would have said or what they're saying
in public is that people like you are
simply confused you've got the wrong end
of the stick that the bill protects free
speech rather than creates the threats
which you say now i will bow to your
legal judgment but what do you think
should happen do you think the bill
should be dropped in its entirety do you
think of illegal but harmful to use this
phrase of censorship should be dropped
as well because i do believe for example
either free speech should be legal or it
should not be and do you think we should
abandon the concept of a third term or
third concept what do you think the
government should be doing now
i think that it should be
defining in the bill itself and not in
ministerial guidance what it regards as
offensive
so that parliament can properly debate
what they want to exclude
now the
what it seems to me the essential
criterion to be applied is it has got to
be capable of exact definition
and it's got to be capable of being
precisely identified in the great mass
of material that is on the internet
for that reason i don't actually have a
problem about what i regard as the main
targets of this legislation
which is pornographic images of being
available to children
people under 18
and
actual illegal content like sexual
exploitation
of
of children or terrorist material
or
websites selling guns or
that sort of thing so all of that i have
no difficulty with
and it seems to me that they could
achieve
a great deal of what ms doria says she
wants to achieve
by keeping it at that
and dropping the bit about legal but
harmful material
okay well let's see if she or whoever
succeeds her then need your advice join
consumption lord sampson thank you very
much for joining us on spectator tv
now the online safety bill may offer a
formal form of censorship but in 1989
the ayatollah in iran decided an
informal form of censorship by
proclaiming a death sentence on salman
rushdie in punishment for writing a
novel the satanic verses which they
regarded as blasphemous so for 33 years
of a novelist has lived under this death
threat and he was struck last weekend at
a book festival he's now critically ill
in hospital in upstate new york but
novelist's lana shriver who writes in
this week's magazine about salman
rushdie and the questions which the
attack on him raises and joins me now
from new york lionel thanks very much
and for joining us on spectator tv you
mention in your book that you see lots
of people defending free speech but you
note a sort of insincerity about that
defense can you say more
well this occasion has certainly
been one for
posturing and
i'm not opposed to posturing first free
speech but it just doesn't cost anything
it's a little cheap
and uh
in real life especially in the legal
system in the uk
uh
there's been a terrible corruption of
the right to free speech it's been quite
curtailed and
i've been discouraged by the especially
by the creation of hate speech laws
uh which uh are defined as
someone is offended you know someone
thinks it's hate speech and therefore
it's hate speech uh it's uh
it means that
um
you know i say something
uh that you think is a little mean or
that
that seems a little racist to you or
something and then suddenly the police
knock on my door i mean with that
broader definition
you don't have free speech anymore
the world is full of weirdos and
there's hardly anything that someone out
there is not going to take offense at
and then you've got that bizarre
category in the uk
of the non-crime hate incident which
goes on your criminal record so it's a
crime that isn't a crime that is
recorded as a crime
um
and in the online safety bill uh which
has not been passed yet and i hope never
is passed in its present form uh there's
that uh
category of content uh
legal but harmful
and that could apply to just about
anything
so
with this raft of legislation uh
i don't think that you can really say
that the uk
government supports free speech and then
there's the cultural sphere where
um you know
poor j.k rowling and again
i never thought i'd say that a few years
ago
um
you know is is viciously attacked for
simply saying
that there's such a thing as um sex that
that
that sex is real but but aren't we
talking about two separate things here
of course if you say something you you
can get a caustic reaction on twitter
but it's not illegal nobody no no police
are being sent after jk rowling for
doing what she is doing and so i wonder
if what you're really talking about is
simply a slightly more rancorous public
note in public discourse i mean you as a
novelist i imagine wouldn't have come
close to any brushes with the actual law
in what you've been writing
well not yet
i think there's an intersection between
these two things and the police have
been knocking on the doors of people who
say things on twitter
that that are objected to
um i agree that uh the cultural sphere
is not the same as the legal one and
it's the legal one that especially
matters
right and but you also argue that you
think that salman rushdie's would-be
censors have actually been quite
successful i mean when the fatwa was
issued in 1989 i imagined it was you
know it would have been the first time
ever that a novelist would have been
given a death threat because of a cleric
who didn't like his or her fiction but
the the words the fatwa was that the
purpose of the fatwa was that so no one
will and dare insult the sacred beliefs
of muhammad henceforth in other words to
set a new president that if you do come
up with what they regard as blasphemy
then you can expect some kind of extra
legal punishment you argue in your peace
that
although salman rushdie is still and
thank god for this alive
they have succeeded
in casting
the
the would-be islamic sensors have
succeeded in creating effectively a
secular rule of blasphemy
yes
they have i mean um
if you look at what's happened in
publishing publishing uh
has become completely paranoid about uh
putting out anything that might seem to
be insulting of islam
and uh
i've heard it multiple places
as if it's a veritable fact that the
satanic verses would never be published
today
and
and i i think that's true and i think
even salman rushdie would have thought
twice about writing it in the current
climate
um so that the fatwa has been broadly
successful
uh
we are
very frightened of offending muslims in
any way
i mean that whole um
rotherham scandal
of about you know the police looking the
other way
where large numbers of mostly pakistani
men
were abusing and even raping
young white girls
well
that's that's rooted in the same problem
it's not just fear of racism it's very
specific
you don't offend muslims
now why are they singled out it's
because of terrorism
and
terrorism works i mean i i spent 12
years in
northern ireland and that was the big
lesson
um
terrorism paid off for the ira in space
uh in the good friday agreement and uh
they're on their their they have
enormous political power now they have
not been punished for all those people
they murdered
so
i mean that's that's the most
discouraging
uh
that's the most discouraging thing about
this entire phenomenon
uh
during the last say 30 years is
is how successful it's been
right but you know
isn't this just simply about decency you
wouldn't people might would get the same
reaction i imagine if you were to say
defamatory things about jews and
that was far more common a couple of
generations ago than it is now and and
surely thank god for that
um i don't think this is just about
decency i think um i mean i
none of us have any problem with decency
uh
but
this is very particular to one religious
faith
and they get treated with kid gloves and
there's a clear reason why
right and but the thing is i can't
imagine
you're itching to write novels and
salman rushdie style you know i mean
it's
on a practical basis does this really
make much difference to the way to the
books you write to the public
discussions which we have the rotherham
case was natori it became notorious
because of the cover-up it now stands as
a great example of why you need to talk
plainly about these things that was
surely the takeaway lesson of that and
after the charlie hebdo massacre you had
um people in solidarity with charlie had
to make this publication in right across
europe so the backlash against these
things surely shows people quite very
committed to to free speech and in spite
of the skirmishes we come close to price
regulation we come close to an online
safety bill but we never seem to quite
cross the threshold and it seems that
you know i guess freedom of speech has
always been in danger but in this
country at least we're still surely on
the right side of the law
i think hate speech laws do cross the
line yeah i differ on that point
and it's worth noting that in the united
states
um hate speech laws
are
in violation of the constitution
so the us does not have hate speech laws
and
and it has hate crimes which i have a
bit of a problem with
also but that's a different issue
um
so
i think these hate speech laws are are
it's a it's a wedge problem and they
have grown only more expansive over the
years because that's
that's the nature of the animal
so
um
you know yes
it can be very moving with the the
charlie hebdo
demonstrations all this sense of
solidarity
well it's but it's cosmetic
uh what really matters is is reality and
what what you are allowed to say and not
say and while i am not personally as a
novelist
terribly constrained um from writing a
a book about
a lot of muslim characters saying
mean things about their own religion
um because that's not especially my my
subject matter but more broadly my
subject matter often
uh
uh various forms of heresy you know
allowing my characters to say things
that that are unpopular
and lately in fiction
uh we don't draw a line anymore uh
between what a character says and what
the author is trying to say through the
character so that that the author is
responsible for for anything that
happens or anyone anything that anyone
says
in in the book
and i do feel somewhat constrained by
that now
my nature in response to that sense of
constraint
is defiance
so
i'm further enticed to say things in
my books and frankly even in my columns
as you know very well
that that that i'm not supposed to
but that is not
uh that is not
what most people uh that's not how most
people respond
to
threats and intimidation and
um broadly i think that most of my
colleagues uh
in the
literary biz
are feeling um
they better get with the program there's
certain things they better not put in
print
there are whole topics that they're
likely to avoid even if they might
otherwise have been attracted to them
you know
and this is
this these are not
even controversial assertions at this
point
okay well lana shriver you've got a book
of your own essays coming out and
released next month in all good
bookshops if they dare to stock it thank
you for joining us on spectator tv
now lionel's last novel the mandibles
had as its premise
that cryptocurrency had become the
reserve currency of the world and the us
dollar lost that status she imagines
dystopia where the u.s dollar then
collapses because crypto is so reliable
everybody trusts it instead well that
certainly does seem like fiction right
now where bitcoin and all the other
cryptocurrencies have crashed rather
spectacularly in the last few weeks
therefore the dream is over or is it in
this week's magazine matthew lynn points
out that there's been something of
revival in the grave of cryptocurrency
he joins me now matthew are you saying
the whole merry-go-round is going to
start again are we looking at another
crypto boom
i mean i i i'd hesitate to go quite that
far and you know it's probably lucky
that that you know you're going to
predict quite yet that is going to
replace the dollar because you know
obviously anyone looking at the
financial markets looking at their
screens the last six months the dollar
has been doing really really well it is
very strong and bitcoin and the other
cryptocurrencies crash spectacularly i
mean you know um down from about sixty
thousand dollars for bitcoin which is
always the main one gets all the
headlines um down to about ninety
thousand dollars i mean that's that's a
heck of a big fault and very very
painful for anyone who holds it um but
you know what's what's been interesting
just in the last six weeks or so is it
started to turn the corner it's gone up
again to
um you know about twenty four thousand
dollars you know that's a significant
rise um will they get back to its
previous peaks well actually you know
the interesting thing about bitcoin is
that it crashes regularly it's an
incredibly volatile asset but unlike a
lot of kind of you know manias where
it's kind of it's classed as a kind of
flimsy mania it crashes and it comes
back and if it does come back if it gets
back to the forty fifty thousand dollar
level this will be the fourth time since
it was created where it's crashed and
come back again and that's something
slightly different
right but but let's talk a little bit
more about why it's crashed i mean those
who love
bitcoin and other cryptos will say that
you can trust it in a way that you can't
trust fiat currency that the government
i mean
lionel's book was basically written on
the idea that governments will always
use inflation to inflate away their own
debt they'll rip off the cons the public
and and that's why people might
ultimately the patients might snap in in
government currency and they'll buy
unregulated crypto because it's safer
now surely right now we've got inflation
soaring and money was printed so as as
people like lionel's driver and others
were warning and money printed today
inflation tomorrow
but it doesn't seem as if anybody's got
any more faith in crypto than they do in
these currencies which are losing their
value in britain at the rate of 10 a
year in america a little bit more
yeah no i think i think that's
absolutely true i mean you know the last
six months um you know they they kind of
took you know the main argument for
cryptos which you just outlined there
and they they they shot it shut it into
pieces it was it was supposed to be a
kind of solid uh it was supposed to be a
digital gold it was like the gold
standard you you know when when carrot
when governments imprinted money and
divorced the currency and inflated their
way out of trouble don't worry your
bitcoin will be fine and then actually
you know inflation came along at 10
percent uh people printed money they
divorced the currency what happened your
bitcoin lost three quarters of its value
so we discovered something interesting
which is it's not that it's not it's not
digital gold uh or at least the evidence
would seem to point in that direction
that it's not a digital call it doesn't
hold its value against inflation
but perhaps perhaps it's something else
you know because you know i think
you know what interested me was it is it
is turning into a real asset it falls
it's very volatile it rises it falls but
each time it rises and falls it rises to
a new level and it finds it finds a new
floor and that's looking a lot more like
you know the equity markets or gold or
the dollar or the bond markets or the
property market uh it's kind of what
happens to assets it's kind of you know
in bitcoin it does it on motor skates so
it does it in a slightly more
accelerated exaggerated way but that
might be because it's new and novel so i
totally agree with you i don't think it
is the new gold um
it's not a hedge against inflation but
it does increasingly look like a real
asset or maybe it's something new that
we haven't quite worked out yet so what
you're saying is this is not like the
dutch tulip bubble this isn't something
which has sort of collapsed back into
thin air this is something which has
taken a knock but it has fallen at a
sufficiently reliable place for us to
think that it's going to be around for
some time to come so you think that the
crypto is here to stay in other words
yeah i think i think that's what's
becoming increasingly true that it's
durable because you know it's very easy
for me to say oh it's like it's like
it's like the dutch tulip mania it's
like the south sea bubble and there's a
long history you'll know all of this a
lot of the viewers will know this you
know the the markets get incredibly
excited about something and it turns out
to be just hot air and nothing at all so
but you think the thing about tulips you
know it inflated you know
a massive bubble and then it burst and
then after that no one was interested in
tulips you know except when they wanted
to plant their garden uh against a
flower through springtime the south sea
bubble you know a huge bubble uh
actually i i checked because the
spectator eaters tend to know this kind
of stuff so i thought i better look it
up actually the sexy company did stagger
on until the middle of the 19th century
but it was nev it never came back as a
as a hot asset in the way that it had
been uh during the great bubble if you
think about the radio boom that led up
to the crash you know radio star then
recovered more recent history the great
japanese asset bubble uh which was you
know the great bubble of the post-war
period probably the greatest bubble of
the post-war period you know the tokyo
market is still a long long way um from
recovering its 1989 high probably won't
ever cover it in your lifetime or my
lifetime so the you know i think the
interesting point is this you know the
bubble baths and everyone moves on they
think oh that was crazy
we really should never have got excited
about tunics or japanese poverty or
whatever it happened to be
but that's not what's happening to
bitcoin uh you know the bubble pops that
happened once twice three times and now
fourth time but each time it comes back
so that's kind of different from a
bubble that's that's not that's not an
investment mania they're starting to
look a little bit more like a real asset
like the property market or like the
bomb market or the equity market so i
think there is you know it's uh once you
get to 12 13 years three or four you
know cycles of boom or bust you've got
to stay back and say maybe this is
something real although we still have a
lot to discover about what it actually
is
and finally matthew i've got um on my
phone the revolut app i've got a revolut
band card and one of the options it now
gives me to sprung up buy bitcoin so i
can buy this at a touch of a button
should i is now the time
i'm not i'm not good you're too smart
right i'm not going to give you
financial advice i mean look you know
the past record which would suggest that
actually it does reclaim uh it does go
above previous highs you know um so if
you're looking at the charts you would
probably say you know when it's gone
from 19 to 24 um it probably you know
the record would suggest that it will go
um
above 60 which was its previous peak um
but you know it may take a little while
let's be cautious about that you know
keep your phone in your pocket for a
little a little while yet okay well
matthew we'll call you back in a couple
of months to see how that prediction
worked out but thank you very much for
joining us on spectator tv
and thank you for watching that's all
we've got time for this week on the week
in 60 minutes
if you haven't tried the spectator
magazine before then do give us a try
we've got
a rather unusually generous introductory
offer right now one pound a week for the
first year you can avail yourself of
this rather uneconomic for us anyway
dot
offer
dot uk forward slash tv offer also you
can subscribe to this show for free the
week in 60 minutes by clicking on the
red subscribe button then if you click
on the bell button you'll be told every
time there's a new episode so thanks to
max jeffrey our producer and kate
andrews will be presenting next week
until then goodbye
[Music]
you